la construction de ce lycée
international est un peu à la fois
magnifique et c'est aussi dernière parce
que il est possible il ne sera plus
possible de compenser conditions un
dernier établissement en ciment les
nouveaux bâtiments du collège lycée
franco allemand de buc représente la fin
d'un cycle
un plan de restructuration académique
présenté par le département
nous allons consacrer sur 50 2021 à 2026
525 millions d'euros à la construction
de 15 nouveaux collèges ça ne veut pas
dire que dans ces cinq ans d'un
n'annoncera pas d'autres car nous
voulons intensifier ce rythme avec
l'idée dont de bio sourcés ces
constructions des projets écologiques
avec des bâtiments issue d'énergies
renouvelables ou de matériaux de
récupération
une diminution de la consommation
actuelle des collèges de 40% et une
faible empreinte carbone en ce moment en
dehors de la coville il ya une espèce
d'inquiétude sur l'évolution climatique
elle est très prégnante notamment chez
les lycéens et les collégiens et je
crois que c'est leur envoyer un beau
message de dire on vous on vous met dans
des conditions qui seront celles du
futur
les futurs effectifs ont été étudiées
pour répondre aux besoins des communes
tout en accueillant les élèves dans les
meilleures conditions
la proposition qui est faite par le
département de construire plutôt des
collèges qui soit aux alentours de 5 600
d'une manière générale c'est pour moi la
bonne dimension pour un collège
on essaie de coller à la réalité par
exemple
aujourd'hui sur aubergenville c'est un
collège neuf cents ils sont six ans donc
il n'ya pas de prévisions nationales ou
locales de dévolution plus importantes
on l'a dit muet à 700 parmi les
dernières incertitudes de discussions
autour d'un nouveau collège à trappes
entre le département et la municipalité
deux autres établissements seront
restructurés sur l'espace saint quentin
en yvelines
lamarre au sol à coignières et le
collège albert einstein de magny les
hameaux
tous devraient être achevés d'ici 2026